Now for the solution to the second problem of Unit 3,
let's start it by adding in a constraint to the system with this line right here about n.
This shows, I've explained earlier, that the total population n remains constant in all times.
The people just switching between the S and I groups.
Now let's move on to the core of the problem.
Switching the contents to the for loop to use the trapezoidal rule
instead of the forward Euler method.
We begin with the standard expressions for Ṡ and İ,
but this time showing that people can move from the infected population
back to the susceptible population directly.
Just for simplicity, I'm going to call our constants a and b right now
and I'll change them later to show what's actually in the code.
Now we can get a single equation that encapsulates
the information in all three of these equations if we just substitute N-I for S in the equation for İ.
This is what this line right here shows.
If we do a little bit of rearranging and simplifying, we get a quadratic equation for I-dot.
Now this make things a lot simpler altogether because now we have one equation
and one independent variable instead of three equations in two independent variables.
Now it's time to move on and use the trapezoidal rule.
You'll notice here that I'm using a t in the subscripts instead of an n this time.
That's just so that we don't get confused between big N's and the little n's.
So we know that for the t+1 time step, I is going to equal this expression just in the trapezoidal rule.
However, we just created an equation for I-dot that depends only on I.
So we can plug that expression in to get this expanded equation right here.
Since many of the terms in this expression have factors of h/2 and a outside of them,
I'm just going to pull out a factor of ha/2.
With a little bit of rearranging, we come up with this long expression.
Now we can think of this equation as made up of two parts--
one part that involves I sub-t+1 and another part that just involves I sub-t.
Since we want to think of I t+1 as the only independent variable,
we can lump everything else under other variable names.
Looking at the equation, we have one term with (I subt+1)² .
A couple of terms with I t+1¹ and several terms that don't have I t+1 at all
and we're going to call everything that's in front of I t+1¹p.
And we're going to call everything that doesn't involve at all q and this is going to give us
the simplified quadratic expression that shows very clearly
how this is a quadratic equation using I sub-t+1.
Using the quadratic formula and rearranging a little bit, we get this expression right here
using p and q to express I sub-t+1.
Now this actually has two possible solutions--
one with a plus sign here and then one with the minus sign here.
So how do we decide which one to pick? Well we know that this h to times that goes to zero.
We want I sub-t+1 and I sub-t to get closer and closer together
since the curve is going to become smoother and smoother.
Since p has a term of 1/h inside of it, this means that p is going to infinity as this happens.
If we pick the minus sign over here, they're going to have minus infinity,
which means that I-sub-t + 1
is definitely going to go to negative infinity and this is definitely not what we want.
So just to be safe, we will pick the plus sign here.
Now we return to the code where we've translated our expressions for p and q into Python.
To do this, we have to remember that the coefficients a and b that we were using
when we're writing things by hand actually each have different names in the code.
A is equal to a transmission coefficient and b is equal to one over the infectious time.
Using this information, you've just done a simple translation of p and q into Python.
This makes writing out the expressions for I step+1 and S step+1 very easy.
For I step+1, we just write in the solution that we got from using the quadratic formula
using of course the plus sign right here in the variables p and q
since they are just written right here anyway.
Because we know that I plus S is always equal to n,
our expression for S is simply equal to n-I at the time step.
Now, let's run this first with step size 0.5 and see what happens. This looks very nice.
We have two really smooth curves with the infectious population is green
and the susceptible population is blue just like in the last problem.
We see that since each curve in the plot approaches a constant value at long times
we're approaching a steady state situation.
Now let's run the program instead with step size 10.
So this is what we get from our model if we're using h=10 instead of h=0.5.
Even though now that the curves is particularly smooth,
we can see that they obey the same overall pattern as we saw in our graph using the smaller step size.
The most important thing is that we still are approaching
a stead state situation at the end of the graph.
Now think back to what happen when you run the supplied code like we ask you to.
When you run the supplied code with h=0.5, you should have gotten a graph that looks like this.
This definitely looks a lot like what we saw when we run the solution code using h=0.5 as well.
However, let's peek at what happen when you use h=10 using the forward Euler method.
You can see that there are a lot of differences between this and the graph that we just saw
and also between this and the graph with the solution code when we had h=10.
The most important thing to notice though is what's happening over here in this region.
You can see that instead of each curve approaching one set value as time goes on
they keep crossing paths at each other.
In other words, since I and S here don't obey nearly the same trend that they do
with smaller step sizes, this shows that the forward Euler method doesn't allow for stability
with large step sizes nearly as well as implicit methods like the trapezoidal method do.
Hope that was an interesting investigation with the difference between implicit methods
and other kinds of methods and get ready for the last problem of Unit 3.